[Music]
that's Emma stay tuned because jason
mraz is coming up next as part of the
kia summer music series that's right
excite about this kia is sponsoring all
of our great musical guests this summer
and speaking of which I just want to
mention something there's a guy out
there who we found out about whose name
is Daryl Rhodes there he is he's a yeah
that's a candid shot of him he's a
self-described rock-and-roller who has
been waging a youtube campaign to become
part of the kia summer music series now
it's hard to believe but so far kia has
declined to sponsor daryl I don't know
why based on that photo as they they've
declined to sponsor Daryl as a musical
guest on our show so Daryl has contacted
us he's asked us to make a live plea
directly to Kia he begged me
he's been bothering me for weeks I gave
in here he is please give a warm welcome
to rock-and-roller
Daryl Rhodes okay yeah I know you're
watching tonight and I'm about to
totally win you over with a song I wrote
about my favorite Kia car the Kia Optima
lemonade all the Kia Optima the best car
around when you drive around town you're
really getting down drive it to the
store drive it to your job but don't
drive it while you're eating corn on the
cob
driving up your leg you feel cool like
you just graduated from awesome school
flashback Daryl Rhodes you're the
greatest person ever to graduate from
awesome school hi yes you are and don't
forget the Kia Optima Limited has power
folding mirrors and a panoramic sunroof
that's awesome rockin hands
[Applause]
Carol just that was an amazing song but
if you're gonna sing about a Kia Optima
limited you might as well use the real
thing and here it is there isn't that
exciting
[Applause]
[Music]